bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 19 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal on
commence ce site avec les titres de
cette édition les départements de france
et notamment ceux de la grande couronne
tire la sonnette d'alarmé en cause un
budget impacté par les diminutions des
dotations de l'état dans les yvelines la
baisse frôle les 132 millions d'euros
l'écrivain michel tournier s'est éteint
à 91 ans l'homme de lettres s'était
installé à choisel en 1957
nous l'avions rencontré en 2001 nous les
rendrons hommage dans cette édition
et enfin le petit robot filet qui
s'était posé sur la comète souris ne
donne plus signe de vie
la mission rosetta peut-elle quand même
être qualifié de succès nous y
reviendrons avec cyril saux pas
chercheur a lobé est-ce qu invité de ce
journal et dont l'actualité de ce mardi
19 janvier la disparition à 91 ans de
l'écrivain michel tournier
il s'est éteint il hier à son domicile
un ancien presbytère à choisel dans les
yvelines où il s'était installé en 1957
le département qu'il connaissait bien
pour avoir fait ses études au collège
sainte et robert de saint germain en
laye en 1941 il avait quitté la maison
familiale occupée par l'armée allemande
michel tournier avait reçu en 2001 les
équipes de tv fil 78 alors qu'il
préparait la publication d'un nouvel
essai journal extime prix goncourt en
1970 pour le roi des aulnes
il écrivait également pour la jeunesse
avec des oeuvres comme vendredi ou les
limbes du pacifique ou encore vendredi
où la vie sauvage les deux oeuvres
inspirées du livre de robinson crusoé
ont marqué plusieurs générations
d'écoliers regarder on est chez moi
parce que j'habite le presbytère de
choisel depuis 45 ans et j'ai écrit tout
ce que j'ai publié et c'est devenu une
partie de moi-même cette maison on se
rend compte que vous faites partie du
patrimoine maintenant et j'espère enfin
pas trop parce que chaque côté un petit
peu funèbre un tiers parti n'a pas de
prix nous nous amusons provisoire
vous imaginez qu'un jour votre maison
pour être le lieu d'un inculte d'un
pèlerinage j'espère que non mais chiche
est telle qu'un jeu c'est pas grave
toute façon un presbytère est une maison
très honorable et je les laissais et je
n'y ai pas touché jeu léché tel quel et
françois hollande a publié un communiqué
dans lequel ils louent l'immense talent
d'un grand écrivain le chef de l'état a
ajouté michel tournier était un grand
écrivain un écrivain européen dont
l'oeuvre a traversé le xxème siècle est
marqué l'histoire de la littérature
nous reviendrons sur sa disparition
mercredi dans le magazine culturel
kiosques et vendredi dans l'édition du
journal de fin de semaine vous pourrez
re découvrir l'intégralité de
l'interview qui nous avait accordé en
2001 la ville de montigny le bretonneux
est une des premières communes des
yvelines à s'être équipé de caméras
aujourd'hui elle continue sa politique
d'extension de son maillage de
vidéosurveillance relié directement au
centre de sécurité urbaine ces caméras
permettent aux policiers municipaux
d'agir rapidement et aussi ni mon teint
d'être rassurés on les remarque à peine
pourtant elles se multiplient à montigny
le bretonneux
à condition bien sûr de savoir aussi que
pour les gens les prévenir noms qui
seront filmés
moi ça ne me dérange pas on n'a rien à
se reprocher aux caisses aussi ça permet
quand même de contrôler des situations
dans des coins est fragile qui peut
poser problème
on décembre une nouvelle caméra a été
installée près de la gare en moyenne
chaque année deux caméras sont
installées dans la commune dont la
politique de surveillance remonte au
début des années 2000 nous avons refait
ya un an ou deux maintenant notre centre
de supervision urbaine et puis nous
rajoutons des caméras et nous changeons
aussi certaines de caméras avec m dans
tout ce qui se fait de mieux dans le
domaine technique caméra infrarouge très
haute définition ou encore 360° là comme
une pionnière en la matière ressent 62
caméras à l'extérieur et aux abords de
ces équipements
là on est aussi en train de réfléchir
sur un plant et une caméra mobile c'est
à dire que messieurs qu'à un moment
donné sur un quartier des faits nous
sont signalés et à partir du moment où
on pourra installer une caméra mobile
ça va nous permettre pendant quatre cinq
mois 6 mois de surveiller plus
particulièrement un quartier une
politique de surveillance qui a un coût
installer une caméra coûte entre 15000
et 20000 euros à la commune en 2015 à
montigny le bretonneux 165 faits
délictuels ont été constatés par ces
caméras
les experts présents deux politiques
avec vous vous le ferez de bonsoir
bonsoir florane de politique et de
finance les départements sont dans le
rouge une dizaine d'entre eux annoncent
être au bord du gouffre en cause la
diminution des dotations de l'état
l'état veut obliger les collectivités à
faire des économies mais pour continuer
à investir et surtout à verser les
prestations sociales il n'y a pas
beaucoup de solutions qui s'offrent aux
élus locaux
la baisse des dotations pour les
yvelines représente tout de même 130 2
millions d'euros cela signifie donc une
hausse d'impôt un exemple toujours dans
les yvelines les contribuables
propriétaires vont devoir payer 125
euros de plus sur leur taxe foncière
pierre bédier que vous voyez à l'image
le président du département des yvelines
et ses homologues de seine-et-marne de
l'essonne du val d'oise se sont réunis
au sein d'une association grande
couronne capitale et ils viennent de
donner une conférence de presse commune
avec un seul mot d'ordre est dénoncée en
les écoutant waterloo sociale lorsqu'on
est face à ses difficultés
la solution de facilité notamment dans
mon département aurait été de placer
l'essonne sous faillite ça signifier
pour les contribuables une augmentation
des impôts de 70%
nous nous sommes refusés à cette
solution qui n'en était pas une
et nous avons pris des décisions
courageuses qui concerne d'abord des
mesures d'économies et tous les
départements prennent des mesures
d'économies
qui sont difficiles pour tous mes
collègues mais malheureusement ces
mesures d'économie ne suffisent pas et
nous devons faire appel aux
contribuables
on a pas de trésor caché au napa de de
comptes dans les paradis fiscaux qui ont
rapatrié en france
donc nous nous sommes obligés
malheureusement d'aller prendre l'argent
là où il est c'est à dire dans les
poches des contribuables alors ce qui
complique les finances des départements
c'est l'augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires des aides sociales rsa est
de l'autonomie les départements reverse
ses prestations sociales et regard de la
situation économique actuelle avec un
chômage qui progresse les demandes sont
forcément hausse moins d'argent dans les
caisses plus de dépenses les
départements de la grande couronne
envisage de mutualiser pour réduire
leurs frais précise tout de même que les
yvelines ont déjà réalisé pour 2016 25
millions d'économies si tous les
départements de la grande couronne sont
dans cette situation c'est probablement
qu'il ya une explication unique
si tous les départements de france à
travers l'association des départements
de france dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons sont dans une situation
difficile
ça n'est pas simplement à cause de leurs
présidents de conseils départementaux
c'est bien parce que le gouvernement
socialiste est dans l'absurdité totale
et je tiens à le dire avec force par
votre intermédiaire si demain le
gouvernement socialiste devient
raisonnable et nous rendre cet argent
immédiatement ou le rendront aux iguanes
n'avons pas besoin pour nous nous en
avons besoin pour maintenir le niveau
des prestations sociales que l'état me
demande de faire en son nom et on se
souvient aussi que le département des
yvelines envisage très sérieusement une
fusion avec les hauts-de-seine toujours
pour mutualiser les moyens
alors ce que l'on entend souvent c'est
le mot faillite on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure pour l'essonne est ce que c'est
vraiment possible pas de faillite pour
un département mais une mise sous
tutelle de l'état c'est une décision
extrême et ensuite le préfet a tous les
moyens pour imposer les mesures qu'il
juge nécessaires pour redresser les
comptes
mais avant d'imaginer une telle
situation et même si les difficultés
sont réelles n'oublions pas non plus que
2016 est une année tremplin avant les
échéances électorales de 2010 7 et les
départements de droite comme les régions
et c'est le cas en ile-de-france ont
tout intérêt à critiquer ce gouvernement
socialiste de manière caricaturale on
pourrait dire qu accusé le gouvernement
a de la hausse des impôts ça ne peut
qu'aider à gagner quelques points dans
les sondages
merci wilfried on vous retrouve vendredi
pour le journal le journal de la semaine
et dès 18h dont continue politique avec
les voeux des élus qui se poursuivre
tout au long de ce mois de janvier
vendredi dernier c'était au tour du
maire les républicains de maurepas de
s'adresser aux personnalités et
habitants de sa commune
c'était sa première cérémonie depuis son
arrivée à la tête de la commune en
raison des attentats de janvier dernier
l'événement avait été annulée c'est donc
avec une certaine émotion qui s'est
exprimée avec à ses côtés le responsable
de la nouvelle agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi le député
de la circonscription et candidat à la
primaire à droite pour 2017 jean
frédéric poisson
parmi les annonces on retiendra
l'annoncé de la création d'un nouvel
écoquartier d'un pôle culturel ou encore
les rénovations qui vont se poursuivre
dans les écoles le maire a aussi profité
de la cérémonie pour maintenir la
pression sur l'agglomération quant à la
réalisation d'une nouvelle piscine dans
les prochaines années
je l'annoncé nous allons reconstruire
une nouvelle piscine puisque l'étude de
faisabilité nous a bien indiqué que ç'a
coûté aussi cher de réhabiliter que de
construire un équipement tout neuf
donc je prends mes responsabilités je
suis garant de l'argent public et donc
nous partirons sur un équipement tout
neuf avec les dernières technologies
c'est un projet quand même ambitieux qui
va coûter plusieurs millions d'euros il
faut pas se tromper il faut aller avec
tout le recul possible d'analyser les
pour et les comptes sur le montage
financier puis ensuite on démarre à les
appels d'offres pour commencer les
travaux et les maires a aussi annoncé le
lancement d'une nouvelle étape dans son
projet de démocratie participative
écoutez c'est une première dans les
yvelines nous allons allons lancer le
premier budget participatif citoyens
auprès de tous les moyens donc nous
allons fléché au budget d'investissement
2016 une enveloppe de cent cinquante
mille euros
les morts patients pour déposer un
projet qui souhaite voir naître sans
repas il y aura une sélection après par
un jury et ensuite ce sera soumis au
vote des morts patients et le projet où
les projets retenus dans l'enveloppé de
150 mille euros seront réalisés sur la
ville et vendredi soir avaient également
lieu la cérémonie des voeux de 2016 de
la verrière une cérémonie de voeux
citoyens préparé par les habitants où
chacun prenait
la parole une année placée sous le signe
de la fraternité et de la résistance
durant cette soirée alain ajaj le maire
de la ville a annoncé aux habitants
qu'ils décidé de renvoyer au président
de la république sa médaille de
chevalier de l'ordre du mérite qu'il
avait reçu 15 ans plus tôt un geste
symbolique pour exprimer son
mécontentement face à la politique du
gouvernement actuel
une dernière information la ville de
bois d'arcy lance son application c'est
la nouveauté de ce début d'année 2016
l'application mobile gratuite et permet
de rester informé sur l'actualité de la
ville les événements les agendas ou
encore les travaux
elle permet également de signaler
n'importe quel problème dans la commune
comme par exemple en défaut de la
chaussée elle est disponible sur google
play et apple store et s'il ne faut pas
chercher à l'aube est ce qu était avec
nous en plateau bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation nous allons
parler donc de filet avec vous la
mission rosetta bouquet classons de
filet le petit robot laboratoire qui
s'est posé sur la comète de souris vous
avez donc travaillé sur ce projet
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus de
nouvelles
pouvez vous nous dire à propos justement
de ces missions est bien dans ses
missions très original de l' agence
spatiale européenne puisque c'est la
première avoir mis en orbite autour
d'une comète un satellite et avoir
transporté un petit module qui s'est
posée qui s'appelle chilean donc c'est
une première technologique et c'est la
première fois qu'on allait voir aussi
près la surface d'une comète qui sont
des objets fascinants puisque ce sont
des reliques du système solaire très
ancien est donc allé étudier ces objets
comme les astéroïdes c est finalement
étudié les reliques de systèmes cela qui
s'est créée il ya 4 milliards d'années
environ
donc c'est très intéressant donc au delà
du défi technologique
on a on a eu un grand succès
scientifiques grâce à cette batterie
n'avons plus de nouvelles de la
sentinelle
ça reste une réussite pour vous voilà
donc malheureusement aujourd'hui très
très peu d'espoir de reprendre contact
avec la sonde pour les questions
d'énergie et de communication s'ils
voulaient que ça les poser sur un côté
qui n'était pas voilà alors il ya
plusieurs facteurs qui rentrent en
compte six à la température de la comète
qui se refroidit qu'il n'est pas propice
fils et finalement à une conservation de
l'énergie à l'ensoleillement des
panneaux solaires qui alimentent la
batterie qui n'est pas non plus très
bonne et s'ils voulaient le champ de
vision des antennes et sûrement obscurci
par le fait que l'as on s'est couché sur
le côté alors qu'elle était sans
c'est évidemment se poser sur ses pieds
donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on a
perdu tout contact et on pense qu'on y
arrivera on n'arrivera plus à prendre
contact avec elle mais néanmoins toutes
les mesures qui ont été faites à
l'atterrissage de 12 novembre 2014 ont
été ont été publiés aujourd'hui dans des
journaux scientifiques qui nous ont
apporté des informations très
intéressantes auxquelles on n'a pas
accès depuis l'orbité de la commune
alors justement à quoi va vous servir
ces informations sur la comète va y
avoir d'autres projets après eh bien on
a appris énormément de choses qu'on ne
savait pas avant notamment la
composition de surface de la comète sa
structure et sa densité est donc ça
ouvre des perspectives quant à
l'élaboration nouvelles missions qui
doivent aller investiguer de manière
plus amplifier le noyau cométaire et
donc à des projets aujourd'hui qui
commence déjà à être établies afin
d'envoyer des missions vers des communes
dans les décades qui viennent la sonde a
découvert des molécules c'est ça surfe
l'oeil sur la comète louis dont il ya
deux instruments qui étaient chargés
d'analyser la composition chimique du
cométaire dont une expérience développée
à l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en partie et donc parmi les
ingrédients qu'on a réussi à analyser
dans ces grains on a trouvé des
molécules organiques qui sont très
intéressante pour la formation du vivant
et on imagine que les comètes ont pu
apporter une partie des ingrédients sur
la terre primitive
là où l'alchimie a pu générer la vie
telle qu'on la connaît de manière
primitive sous forme de bactérie et qui
a donné lieu aux organismes vivants que
connaît aujourd'hui dont nous que
finalement les comètes peuvent être un
peu nos parents très très lointain votre
votre mission aujourd'hui se termine sur
sur rosetta vous allez continuer comment
ça va se passer un peu pour pour la
suite il était également votre mission
qu'elle était est ce que vous faisiez
pratiquement enfin si on peut parler de
façon de se garer d'accord et le disons
que j'ai eu la chance d'arriver en cours
de ma thèse de doctorat sur ce projet
donc ça fait très longtemps de foudre
on a vers les années 2000 et donc
j'essuie j'ai développé une partie de
l'instrument qui a détecté ces molécules
chimiques et donc après ma mission ça a
était d'interpréter les mesures alors
aujourd'hui malheureusement pour cet
instrument on travaille encore à des
expériences de laboratoire pour essayer
d'interpréter au mieux les données qu'on
a eu
ce qu'on a fait qu'une première
interprétation mais malheureusement
l'essentiel du travail a été fait mais
la mission continue aujourd'hui et
rosetta encore à satellites autour d'eux
encore un satellite autour d'une comète
et donc les études continuent
malheureusement en ce qui me concerne le
travail est terminé
à ce niveau là c'est une grande avancée
pour le milieu scientifique européen par
rapport notamment j'espère aux
américains oui oui c'est une grande
avancée est une réussite parce que
évidemment nos collègues américains avec
qui j'ai eu le plaisir de travailler
évidemment ont beaucoup plus de moyens
et on voit beaucoup plus de missions
spatiales dans l'espace mais les comètes
depuis l'admission julio tour 1986
finalement sont un peu une chasse gardée
européenne puisque kyoto a été la
première mission a survolé une comète en
1986 la comète de halley et donc par ce
cet exploit un peu technologique
d'envoyer un petit module à la surface
d'une comète ni à l'europe a gardé un
petit peu ça sa prérogative sur la
science comme et on l'a vu a également
sur le web sur les réseaux sociaux le
sort du vad là son 2e filet un peu ému
les internautes les beaucoup voilà de
tweets sur justement son sort comment
vous l'expliquez que ce petit robot
laboratoire iot autant sympathie parce
qu'il a subi une aventure extraordinaire
si vous voulez c'est à dire qu'il a il a
rebondi à la surface d'une comète et il
aurait pu lui arriver
énormément de péripéties c'est à dire
repartir dans l'espace interplanétaire
se retrouver perdu par rapport à la
sonde rosetta mais finalement il a il a
fini par se poser définitivement sur la
comète ce qui n'était pas forcément ce
qu'ils étaient difficilement prévisibles
en termes de résultats puisque par
exemple on n'avait aucune idée de la de
la densité de surface de la comète et
certains imaginer que que filahi
pourrait s'enfoncer dans dans la matière
cométaire qui était très poreuse donc
voilà je pense que l' aventure
extraordinaire le fait que ce soit déjà
une réussite technologique une réussite
scientifique et cette aventure qu'a eu
ce petit robot pendant presque 24 heures
et est assez porteuse si vous voulez de
d'exploit une dernière question avant de
nous quitter donc là son filet ça s'est
un peu terminer la mission rosetta
continue la prochaine étape donc on va
peut-être parler
la très très prochainement est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus on
continue à suivre la comète sur sa
trajectoire donc ça nous apporter des
informations sur son évolution par
rapport à sa distance au soleil et puis
il a été décidé que on allait essayer de
poser justement ce satellite sur la
surface de la de la comète donc ce n'est
pas un atterrisseur nous on n'est pas
sûrs du résultat mais si cela est un
succès et bien on pourra encore de
nouvelles informations et notamment des
images très précises de la surface à un
autre endroit d'où celui s'est posée par
nos fils à l'exclusion merci beaucoup
cyril saux pas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions vont savons à présent un peu
plus sur le destin de filet ch
passons maintenant à un tout autre sujet
du 19 au 22 janvier les jeunes
trappistes élisent leur nouveau conseil
municipal des jeunes
cinquième mandat pour cette instance
créée en 2006 elle donne aux collégiens
l'opportunité de s'impliquer dans la vie
locale mais aussi d'appréhender leur
citoyenneté
sephora namani william el est patrick
jacques de dixmude pour ce reportage
vous n'êtes pas aujourd'hui pour élire
vos représentants du pont s'est déjà en
ce tour et candidat à l'élection du
nouveau conseil des jeunes de trappes
propose le développement des spas ce
jeune public des espaces des deux
devoirs ou de lutte contre le racket ou
encore la création de studio de rap
j'ai présenté d'abord pour que les
habitants de rappeler une meilleure vie
et vie si un club c'est ce trappistes de
12 à 16 ans seront élus du 19 au 22
janvier pour renouveler le conseil
municipal des jeunes élus pour deux ans
cette instance créée en 2006 à trappes
permet aux jeunes d'organiser sorties
culturelles actions solidaires et
citoyennes ainsi que des voyages
d'études
c'est un sens ce qui permet aux jeunes
donc d'être de s'engager dans la vie
locale dans la vie démocratique
donc c'est un exercice ça nous permet
également d'exercer levy-hinte actes
simples citoyens changement de formule
pour ce nouveau mandat
dorénavant une assemblée plénière se
tiendra une fois toutes les trois
semaines pour améliorer l'organisation
des projets thématiques bilan du conseil
sortant néanmoins positif trois jeunes
élus se réengagent nous mêmes comme on
est jeune et bon c'est ce que les jeunes
aiment ce que lorsque les jeunes de nos
générations zèle ce qu'ils aiment pas
donc on peut situer c'est aider les
autres c'est investir dans autant
s'investir pour les autres et s'investir
pour moi même parce que je mets premiers
pas dans la vie citoyenne
une action citoyenne qui se prolonge
pour certains gènes ou conseils de
quartier voire même en conseil municipal
mais en attendant résultats de
l'élection mardi 26 janvier à la mairie
de trappes culture à présent pour les
groupes amateurs il est parfois
difficile de trouver un lieu pour se
rassembler répéter sans déranger le
voisinage
plusieurs communes à mettre à
disposition des salles de répétition et
d'enregistrement c'est le cas de la
batterie à guyancourt nickel et demi
d'euros et mes amis potier pour ce
reportage
je suis
et
moi
quant à tommy groupe local vient tous
les vendredis à la batterie de
guyancourt trois heures de répétitions
chaque semaine pour ces quatre amis qui
recherchent qualité et encadrement comme
on joue du rock comme on joue très fort
comme on joue avec une batterie si
l'acoustique est bien ce serait
impossible de jouer dans un appartement
on dérangerait les voisins nos questions
on est dans une installation à sonoriser
donc on peut faire tout bruit qu'on veut
on gêne personne
c'est vrai qu'on a la chance d'avoir ça
c'est tout récent c'est les locaux sont
neufs cécile idéal pour répéter c'est
l'idéal les animateurs de la batterie
ont beaucoup d'expérience les animateurs
ont joué dans des groupes soient des
groupes professionnels ou
semi-professionnels
ils ont fait de la scène ils connaissent
le milieu artistique
la composition l'écriture istin donc il
nous aide la structure accueille une
quarantaine de groupes majoritairement
des habitués elle propose ainsi depuis
2007 trois studios mais aussi de
l'accompagnement matériel et technique
il faut pas répéter n'importe comment il
ya certaines bases avoir une certaine
rigueur si on veut progresser
on leur apprend à se placer lors d'une
répétition à s'écouter jouer sur tout
voilà s'écouter les uns les autres
un studio permet même d'enregistrer ses
morceaux pour repartir avec sa propre
maquette et pourquoi pas un jour
dépasser le cadre amateur est toujours
en culture jusqu'au 30 janvier les
médiathèques se met aux couleurs de la
bande dessinée avec le festival la bd
dans tous ses états expositions
rencontres et ateliers sont au programme
samedi dernier la médiathèque anatole
france situé à trappes proposé un
atelier autour du manga
encadré par un membre de l'association
qui est jesse spécialiste du mondial
les participants ont pu apprendre ou
peaufiner leurs techniques de cet art
japonais écouter les médiations weeds ou
un dessin n'ont pas forcément il ya des
des mangaka qui des scènes très mal mais
qu'il faut enfin très mal qu'il dessine
pas très bien et qui qui sont un très
grand succès par exemple en ce moment il
ya la taille des titans c'est un titre
très très en vogue et le début est très
mal dessinée et la suite s'améliore bien
sûr manga c'est de la pincée de la bande
dessinée un c'est pas de la bande
dessinée européenne mais c'est de la
bande dessinée et tout le monde sait que
c'est de la bande dessinée qui a
beaucoup de succès aujourd'hui donc
c'est ça correspond à des fonds qu'on
prête énormément et beaucoup de demandes
et pour finir un mot de ce sport les
semaines se suivent et se ressemblent
pour le plaisir ugb club les yvelinois
ont enregistré leur neuvième victoire de
la saison en fédérale 3 les plaisirs roy
se sont largement imposés à domicile
contre dunkerque sur le score de 41 à 5
le résumé du match est signée michael
almy d'euros
on ne les arrête plus plaisir leader de
la poule de fédérale 3 avant les fêtes a
conservé son trône
les événements se sont largement imposés
contre dunkerque sur le score de 41 5
une démonstration collective on a eu des
séquences de jeu qui était vraiment
magnifique collectivement et avec des
escales au bout en plus donc ce qui a
fonctionné ce qui commence à bien
fonctionner c'est çà et là on est un
petit peu satisfait parce que on
travaille pour ce à quoi les pzero ans
pourtant batailler en première période
le score n'était que de 14 à 5 à la
pause à la mi-temps on sait on s'est mis
un petit coup de boost on s'est dit que
c'était important de montrer autre chose
montre un autre visage sur le deuxième
mi temps et du coup bas chose qu on a
fait quand on a resserré un petit peu
tout ça sur la deuxième et cherchez la
différence sur le match france
avec cette performance plaisir affiche
désormais un bilan de neuf victoires en
dix matches disputés cette saison
fédérale 3 un parcours qui devrait les
propulser en fédérale 2 l'année
prochaine
tous les dimanches on a à coeur de
prouver que bon bah on n'était pas en
fédérale 2 en arrière pour rien et et on
l'a dit notre objectif c'est de remonter
donc voilà il faut le prouver tous les
week-ends on reste très humble match de
rugby c'est un match de rugby
anouk incarnant la grosse tête plaisir
se déplacera sur le terrain d'evreux
pour le compte de la 11e journée du
championnat l'équipe que les yvelinois
avait dominé 17 à 6 lors des phases
aller c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec new rally
nagloo pour le 7-8 société au programme
comment les villes et répond-t-elle au
demande croissante d'installations de
fast food et quelles conséquences en
termes d'emploi d'emploi pardon le débat
à suivre
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
une nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal
je vous souhaite donc une excellente
soirée